je vous le dis depuis le premier jour et
cela jusqu'aux derniers mois j'aurai
toujours la même humilité nous ne savons
pas tout on fait chaque jour sans doute
des erreurs on essaie de faire au mieux
le tout est de corriger le plus vite
possible ces erreurs est ce que le 29
janvier nous aurions dû confiner le pays
comme certains le disaient comme des
modèles montrer que nous allions flambé
en février écoutez nous l'avons
collectivement nous en avons fait
l'expérience collective réel non et donc
je peux vous le dire nous avons eu
raison de ne pas confiner la france à la
fin du mois de janvier
parce qu'il n'ya pas eu l'explosion qui
était prévu par tous les modèles
donc je peux vous affirmer la cette fois
ci que je n'ai aucun mea culpa faire n'y
ait aucun remord n'ai aucun constat
d'échec
nous avons eu raison de le faire parce
que nous considérions que c'était un
risque qui était qui était là le virus
tourner le zéro virus n'existe pas il
n'existe dans aucun pays de l'europe
nous ne sommes pas une île et même une
les îles qui s'en était protégé parfois
voir ce virus revenir mais nous
considérions que avec les mesures de
couvre-feu qui était prisée les mesures
de freinage qui étaient les nôtres nous
pouvions faire face sans qu'il y ait de
flamber c'est ce qui s'est passé à
partir du début du mois de mars et
l'inflexion s'est passé entre le 8 et le
10 mars il y a eu une accélération que
vous avez vues dans les taux d'incidence
est très rapidement ensuite assez
d'ailleurs de manière assez surprenante
dans les entrées en réanimation et
maintenant le voit y compris dans les
hospitalisations ou les appels aux
médecins
les choses se sont accélérées ceci
correspond au fait que le variant en
particulier le variant britannique est
devenu très majoritaire dans plusieurs
départements
et donc nous avons adapté notre réponse
en prenant des mesures de freinage
supplémentaires renforçant notre notre
capacité à tester alerte est protégé et
la semaine dernière c'est ce qui a
conduit le gouvernement après avoir mis
une vingtaine de départements sous
surveillance renforcée de prendre ces
mesures de freinage avec des contraintes
supplémentaires très forte télétravail
contraintes justement dans la vie
sociale
dans seize départements qui ont été
complétés ce soir par le ministre de la
santé dans trois départements
c'est du pragmatisme c'est du
pragmatisme et donc en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie nous adaptons
la réponse pour pouvoir freiner mais
vous savez il nous faut prendre en
compte plusieurs facteurs
évidemment la dynamique de l'épidémie de
covile 19 les autres pathologies qui
sont là la santé mentale qui se traduit
aussi avec des conséquences lorsqu'on
referme qu'on réduit la vie sociale
qu'on isole la tension qui existe et les
difficultés pour nos jeunes pour qu'ils
en particulier ces mesures sont très dur
à vivre
notre priorité éducative qui fait que
lorsqu'on ferme tout ça a des
conséquences et les conséquences
économiques et sociales et c'est à
chaque fois une balance que nous tenons
et donc je considère que nous avons eu
raison le 29 janvier de ne pas prendre
de mesures de fermeture que nous avons
eu raison ensuite d'apporter des
premières mesures de freinage et en
fonction de l'évolution de cette
épidémie
nous prendrons toutes les mesures utiles
en temps et en heure et il n'y a à mes
yeux aucun tabou nous devons à chaque
fois voir la réponse la plus adaptée